[Musik]
blutige kämpfe auf den straßen von yang
gon mit wachsender brutalität geht das
militärregime nach dem putsch vom ersten
februar gegen die burmesische
demokratiebewegung vor nahezu 300
menschen wurden inzwischen erschossen
fast 3000 verhaftet und zwei mitglieder
von la und san suu kyis partei national
league for democracy zu tode gefoltert
teile des landes stehen unter
kriegsrecht telefon und internet wurden
teilweise abgeschaltet
doch die proteste gehen unvermindert
weiter
dazu leisten künstler/innen wichtige
moralische unterstützung
die berliner filmemacherin johanna hut
dreht seit jahren filme mit jungen
baumes innen und vertreibt diese
weltweit als antwort auf den putsch
produzierte sie burma spring trendone
einen gemeinschaftlichen kurzfilm junger
burmesischer regisseurinnen über den
aufstand eines ganzen volkes
das ist ja auch das besondere an dieser
bewegung dass sich alle daran beteiligen
das heißt es sind die ärzte dabei die
lehrerinnen und lehrer die banker die
juristen aber auch die hafenarbeiter und
auch die arbeiterinnen und arbeiter die
bei h&m dort in den fabriken arbeiten
also es geht sozusagen durch die gesamte
bevölkerung für mehrmals westlich
orientierte junge bevölkerung ist der
versuch des militärs sie ihrer
inzwischen selbstverständlich gewordenen
freiheiten zu berauben schlicht
unvorstellbar
[Applaus]
aus dem wissen dass ihre widerstands
colao sanssouci in einem schauprozess
verurteilt werden und nie mehr an die
macht zurückkehren soll entsteht eben so
wütend wie stille verzweiflung eine von
unseren filmemacherinnen die hat einfach
auf ihren balkon gestanden
in der in einer in der nacht es war
irgendwie sozusagen komplett dunkel und
die hat einfach irgendwie ich glaube
vier minuten lang nur zwei einstellungen
und man hat einfach nur ihren atem
gespürt und man hat ein polizeiauto was
vorbei vorgesehen und und es war einfach
so eine so eine wahnsinnige stille und
auch die auch so ein bisschen eine angst
was kommt jetzt was was wird passieren
also dass das hat mich sozusagen sehr
fast ich dachte das muss unbedingt in
den film rein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bilder die aber auch belegen wie sehr
das militär mit dem rücken zur wand
steht seit den haushoch verlorene
parlamentswahlen vom november letzten
jahres fürchtet die tat madonnas armee
unter general minol ein um ihre pfründe
und privilegien
mittlerweile fordert die protestbewegung
und eine inzwischen gegründete zivile
parallel regierung im exil deren
vollständige kontrolle durch
demokratische institutionen aus sicht
des militärs ein noch bedrohlichere
szenario denn radikaler als sun tzu chi
wollen die reformer myanmar nun in einem
föderalen staat umwandeln sand
weitreichende autonomie rechten für die
vielzahl bislang drangsalierte
minderheiten vor deren rache sich die
militärs fürchten die beschleunigung der
ereignisse überrascht und beunruhigt
auch viele exil burmesen wie die in
finnland lebende künstlerin war im money
und die auch koproduzenten des kurzfilms
burma spring twenty one ist
die militärs fühlen sich in die ecke
getrieben
einerseits sitzen sie in der falle weil
ihnen der geldhahn zugedreht wird
und am 27 märz ist der tag der
streitkräfte
dann wollen sie ihre macht demonstrieren
ihren sieg über diese bewegung deshalb
beschleunigen sie ihr vorgehen um uns
auf brutale art und weise zu brechen
friedliche sitzblockaden und blumen für
den militärapparat diese erst wenige
wochen alten bilder wurden mittlerweile
von einer weitaus brutaleren
wirklichkeit eingeholt
viele demonstrantinnen sind inzwischen
verhaftet gefoltert oder getötet worden
thomas intellektuelle und künstler innen
suchen deshalb inzwischen nach neuen
heimlichen mitteln des widerstands die
bewegung stark bleiben auch wenn sie
weniger auf der straße stattfinden
können wird und ich denke es wird mehr
im verborgenen stattfinden
es wird mehr über auch über
künstlerische kanäle sein
das ist sozusagen eine eine form des
protests die die über bilder stattfindet
ja sich einfach mitteln bedient die man
sozusagen auch zu hause oder in einem
versteck ausüben kann
die künstlerin weimann und will aus dem
europäischen exil in ihre heimat
zurückkehren um den protest zu
unterstützen
doch die chancen auf eine friedliche
lösung des konflikts stehen schlechter
denn je
sollten sich burmas minderheiten und
ihre militärischen organisationen wie
geplant gegen die burmesische armee
verbünden steht dem land ein blutiger
bürgerkrieg bevor
[Musik]